[Music]
so if thor's hammer is supposed to weigh
as
much as a planet what do you think would
happen if he smashes someone with it
well they wouldn't go flying
they would be completely obliterated i
love the action scenes in marvel movies
but every once in a while
i can't help but think they're holding
back just a little bit especially after
seeing logan
and deadpool we've seen what it looks
like when superheroes
truly unleash their powers today using
vfx we're going to bring some of that to
our favorite marvel movies
what would they look like if they were
rated r
so the first step in this process is
going through some of our favorite
scenes and seeing which ones bend the
rules just a little too much for our
liking we're going to take a look at
these things with
nico and peter what's up guys my name is
peter i'm 21 years old and i'm a fat
marvel nerd i've seen every single
marvel movie i
literally saw iron man in 2008 when it
came out i was like i was 10 years old
i didn't watch the most recent
adventures because i think anytime
somebody breaks like a finale into two
movies i just
don't care about the second movie
was talking about this one all of his
internal organs would be squished from
the the momentum
it's the same with superman when he
catches someone who's fallen out exactly
it exactly would be
dead immediately he his body would just
liquidify it'd be like juice coming out
the feet right there right around
yeah uh iron man if i have cancer from
the gamma radiation right
just construct a scene of like tony
stark in a hospital room
all right so loki so he gets bonked off
his air scooter
i am a god you dull creature and i will
not be
bullied by that
that he's not realistic it would look
like taking a towel dipping it in red
food coloring and then
slapping that wet towel around but is it
because he's a god like he's an
alien technically oh you're right he's
not a god
so if you smacked an alien into a floor
would they die
did iron man flew all the way to
afghanistan there we go yeah more juice
just so he lands in juice
he loses control of his bowels because
he travels so fast
there we go that's the first shot look
at that
that's all death this is like straight
like obliteration
this is like shreds and ryan's got two
true lies when she's like did you kill
them
yeah but they were all bad
[Music]
so this is the opening scene of captain
america sorry just
that guy would be dead that guy would be
playing slice in half
i'm just imagining that blood splat on
the wall like america has wasted like
four upstanding swat team officers that
have all have children who are like two
years old
the visual effects i'll be doing is the
uh crying wife as the car rolls up with
the two like people dressed in suits oh
that's straight up
i shot him in the face wait this scene
is perfect
oh you see blood dripping out of him
right there oh my god
dude right there this guy just gets his
head chopped off by the shield
oh yeah he's done oh he just kicks the
corpse
dude if he just sort of kicks him the
head stays in the spot and the body goes
so after scouring through these scenes
it seems like really some of the best
clips we're finding are in captain
america
we have a superhero and superheroes
fighting
actual humans if they were fighting real
people it would look very different than
what you're seeing in the movie people
would be
decapitated they would have their spines
broken they would kind of turn into
meat sponges and splatter everywhere out
of all the scenes that we could
tweak to make look realistic that one
kind of stands out to me so
we have a lot of work to do we're going
to d these shots up
because we're all going to tackle it as
a team there's gonna be a lot of 2d
compositing maybe a little bit of 3d
work we'll see and then i think at the
very end top it off with a little bit of
sound design to hopefully
make all the extra visuals really pop
this scene is going to feel like
it's straight out of john wade
hey jake what's uh what's going on here
man
i know you guys are getting used to
seeing me and thinking oh there here
comes a brand integration because jake's
on camera
well guess what today is absolutely no
different because this video is
sponsored by squarespace but let me tell
you why that's important
i really think the guys pay a lot more
attention to me
when i'm dressed up as their favorite
characters from pop culture
we have this iron man suit just sitting
here let's see how believable
i pull this off and i think at the end
everyone's gonna learn something about
squarespace
hey guys billionaire playboy
philanthropist tony iron man stark here
i'm gonna go tell the guys a something
or two about squarespace
yeah yeah this is how iron man gets
around
hey are you billionaire do you know
billionaire playboy philanthropist tony
iron man stark i thought i'd come down
here and tell you a little bit about
squarespace
i'd love to hear about their
award-winning customer support
they also allow simultaneous posting
meaning that you can post to your
twitter
facebook and tumblr profiles to my
tumblr as well oh my god yeah look at
how much he's paying attention
hey red it's billionaire playboy
philanthropist tony's iron man stark
here
hey nice to meet you be careful with
those those are those are lasers
did you know that squarespace now
supports audio podcasts meaning that you
can put your podcast
on squarespace so you don't actually
know that see you learn something new
every day
look at how much you paid attention to
me when i said that oh hey nico
hi hey mr stark using squarespace we're
also able to do
multiple contributors that's cool hey
which version of the suit is this
uh this is one of the um early ones he
thinks i'm iron man
hey christian did you know that
squarespace allows for traffic overviews
and content ownership so everything you
post on the website
you own we use it all the time at stark
industries that's why squarespace is the
best
hey that's great i'm glad we're on the
same page thanks tony and just remember
guys hey
guys remember go to squarespace.com
coral crew and get 10 off your first
purchase
it's great meeting everyone see you guys
later oh oh oh
i'll see you later
do you think they believed it
[Music]
all right let me hold the neck forward
i'm picking my teeth and i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna put this in my mouth i was
tasked with this
beautiful shot it's like throwing a
frisbee look he's throwing a frisbee at
him and it kind of ricochets off and the
guy goes
we're thinking well the velocity that
thing's traveling at
is pretty high captain america's shield
is so strong it deflects explosions and
bullets and
lasers hammers so it probably can
slice through a man like butter i'm
cutting him in half i want the bottom
half still the legs are great but
basically i need to replace
his top half with a new top half
resorted to one of my favorite websites
mixamo they have a really great
swat model same model that peter's using
i take that
i basically just deleted the second half
put kind of like
a meatball i threw this like big old
meatball in there and
jammed it up in there man dude mama mia
that's the shot
of him regretting everything i think
he's thinking about his family
his life choices and country and
patriotism is worth more than a paycheck
from an
evil corporation basically a little
color correction and i just kind of add
that
here's what really is making the shot
good the shield bounces back still
if it's slicing through him let's yank
the shield out completely after it hits
him like this
let's just kind of have it carry on for
a little bit more with maybe a little
bit of wobble like
and i think that really helps sell it
now it feels like it's like it feels
like you know it's a slice here so
that's the finishing touch on this shot
we're doing a fan made re-release of the
whole movie rated r
actually that would that would be pretty
dope actually you know this is the proof
of concept for anyone out there who's
interested
all right i'm doing the guy who gets
ostrich knees
so here's the finished shot oh my god
dude yep that works
grunt just turns into an ostrich man so
it's just it's quick and dirty
so here's just the base shot right here
i've gone through i've masked out the
lower half of the legs so i can erase
them
so here he is with his legs painted out
something i noticed because i need to
put legs back in is that his leg
rotates just the right way that would
match the perspective shift or i can see
the bottom of
his feet after they flip up all the way
i stuck my
two ostrich legs and here we go
next up is the guy who gets hit in the
neck with captain america's shield
all right i'm back took me a day i got a
little busy i thought i'd really be
funny to do kind of like one of those
anime things like i could slice but then
when he gets hit
like he breaks into pieces so the very
first thing i had to do was i had to
erase his
head now you can kind of see some
feathering and some issues around it but
once all the other effects are in there
you can't tell so let me put the other
effects in there the next thing i had to
do is i had to cut out the guy's head
then after that
animate it to fall down the last touch
here is i need to put in blood spiders
what i'm looking for with the blood here
is that needs to be
going in the right direction so when the
shield hits them i needed to splatter
out sideways
if i were just to drop that blood and
without any effects this is what it
looked like
totally doesn't match the color is
completely wrong if you look at the
image the image is kind of all one color
and that's because of the smoke and the
lighting so the blood just has to be the
same darkness as the guy
and it looks great and once again it's
not the most
sophisticated vfx shot pretty simple
approach but i didn't have a lot of time
and i'm imagining that a lot of peter's
3d effects are going to steal the show
anyways i
looked over peter's shoulder there's a
lot of good stuff he's working on
just doing some fluid simulations for
this blood using flip fluids a plug-in
for blender which i like very much i was
having a problem before where the blood
was sliding all over the place which
isn't too realistic and flip fluids has
this nice viscosity feature so i can
turn that up a bit
and you can see in the next shot here
it's sticking to the ground and kind of
clumping together a bit more
and it's still kind of janky because
it's a fluid simulation but it looks
just good enough to pass oh i put bugs
on falcon's face
you know if you're flying that fast
you're going to get a load of bugs i
make seven hospitals i decided to do the
falcon head slice here it was actually a
similar effect
to brett's head spin in the keanu video
so we go ahead and paint his head out
we take the original footage and we
stabilize the position to his head
so the head spins around its center of
gravity with sound design this is gonna
be so funny i keep telling sam nico we
have to record our own adr for everybody
screaming
we're gonna add some extra screams and
kind of take it up a notch as far as
audio is concerned i really think the
finishing touch is going to be
fixing up the audio here because the
visuals are going to be substantially
different
so we'll want the sound to match that
we've done this before
you just take the mic and give it a
hundred percent just yelling as loud as
possible
okay sure i'll just do my best and
i'm just gonna wing it
ouch
[Music]
[Applause]
we
[Music]
see how the stock's crashing yeah the
portfolio is just not
the fears
i feel sweaty it's hot in here but we
got some good stuff and it's gonna be
disturbing dude
this is so brutal
oh it's good it's good
what do we got some effects here y'all
boys wanna watch some effects
all the shots are finally done this is
my favorite part of
any video like this where all the shots
finally come together
now there's a lot of shots in here and
honestly i we really have to give it up
to peter
because he he did a lot of stuff on this
he did multiple effect shots
but he also did the sound design for the
whole piece guys
where is peter peter peter peter's
coming up
[Applause]
this is also really really special
because this
is peter's last day in the studio this
summer after which he has to go back to
school and keep learning more things
god damn it here's the original scene
for context here we go
[Music]
here
this is the beginning of civil war right
it's it's okay it's great a great action
scene
captain america uh captain falcon
whatever their names are
they're all actually super powerful
beings you know whipping a metal shield
at somebody would just like
like be all woozy um i'm really curious
to see your shots how they turned out
peter shots as well
i am a little nervous to hear the sound
design because
you lose control a little bit you're
like oh it wouldn't be funny if it's
even crazier and even more over the top
and i'm just hoping that peter has kept
this
at a restrained respectable level that
still honors the original action scene
um yeah you guys watch i'm just gonna
i'll be back so that it's already
an incredible scene here's what happened
to it here we go
[Music]
oh
holy [ __ ] wow
oh my god
wow that was great that was so good
can you guys guess whose screams are
whose
all right so sam was obviously the first
one
see this guy flying down out of the sky
that scouts man
the bugs in the face is so good that's
why he's wearing goggles
i didn't even notice that yeah i'm like
that's a hot clip that was so tasteful
and respectful it's almost like all that
vicarious like cathartic violence you
see in john wick
i would really enjoy a marvel movie if
it was like that i could totally watch
an hour and a half of that how would we
do it without peter i don't know because
he brings this this like
glee to it all oh i'm gonna have to like
step up and try to channel my inner
peter so this was really fun to do and
if you guys can think of any other
really cool scenes in marvel movies that
we should make rated r let us know in
the comments below and
we might just take a crack at it also
consider subscribing so you don't miss
it
oh school dude i'm out of here dude
corridor sucks doc
so we just happened to be working on
making the specific marvel scene r-rated
and it turns out that one of the stunt
performers randomly here on the same day
we're making the scene he's in
are rated yeah what's up guys my first
stunt gig ever was
the elevator fight team and captain
america winter soldier and they pulled
me along
through the journey civil war i'm a
rumble agent cap jumps in
catches us off guard there's victim
number one me right there
he just rips my mask off and then back
kicks me through the door it was a good
time
[Music]
you he's dead
oh with the wings
okay you kick me in half kick me in hat
yes
oh james dead
yeah he's dead that is [ __ ] sick damn
man i replaced your voice we'll have to
re-record you
yeah we should i'm down let's go this is
me getting immortalized in the quarter
digital game
go for it
perfect amazing
yo pleasure
[Music]
if you're watching this i'm already
going up to a place
up north a better place i thought before
i left i would make you guys
one last goof just remember me by you
know me always
making those goofs maybe you can save it
to your desktop and watch it every day
ah
[Music]
oh
uh hopefully you enjoyed this video i
also make music so this is a shameless
plug for that too
under peter france on spotify or
whatever streaming service
see you on the other side
you